[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález nuevo
episodio de crisis política tiene lugar
en sudán después de que un grupo de
militares disolvieron el gobierno
interino y también declararon el estado
de emergencia ahora quedan dudas sobre
el futuro y también el éxito de la
transición pacífica del poder por la que
estaba transitando este país después de
la destitución del ex presidente omar
al-bashir que tuvo lugar en el 2019 en
el siguiente reportaje los ponemos en
contexto sobre los hechos que tuvieron
lugar en este país africano
recientemente y que llevaron a la
destitución del gobierno interino
la ira se extiende por las calles de
sudán barricadas llamas y bloqueos hacen
parte del panorama de la capital tras la
toma del poder por parte de las fuerzas
armadas del país
lo que está haciendo el ejército es una
traición a los ciudadanos ahora es
importante que todos los ciudadanos
sudaneses actúen y salgan a la calle
para impedir que las fuerzas militares
lleven a cabo las operaciones el
descontento se apoderó de los sudaneses
tras el arresto del primer ministro de
la anp doc y otros altos funcionarios
por parte del ejército del país poniendo
fin al proceso de transición democrática
que vivía la nación desde la caída del
dictador omar al bashir en 2019
hemos decidido decretar el estado de
emergencia en todo el país segundo
disolver el gobierno y el consejo
soberano el golpe militar suscitó una
ola de rechazo como el del presidente de
la unión africana el presidente hace un
llamado para que se reanuden las
conversaciones entre los civiles y los
militares en el marco de la declaración
política y el decreto constitucional el
presidente reafirma que el diálogo y el
consenso son el único camino para salvar
el país y su transición democrática
unidos anunció la suspensión de una
importante ayuda financiera de 700
millones de dólares para la transición
sudanesa y manifestó su apoyo hacia la
ciudadanía manning estamos del lado del
pueblo sudanés el pueblo sudanés ha
expresado claramente sus aspiraciones de
que continúe la transición a la
democracia
y continuaremos apoyando esta transición
incluso si es necesario exigiendo
cuentas a los responsables de estas
acciones antidemocráticas
el jefe militar del consejo soberano de
sudán declaró el estado de emergencia y
prometió unas elecciones que se
desarrollarían en julio de 2023 con el
objetivo de pacificar la situación del
país bueno esto los pone en contexto de
lo que ha sucedido en las últimas horas
en este país o en los últimos días allí
en este país africano hay que decir que
ya el primer ministro ha sido liberado y
se encuentra en su casa con su esposa y
aparentemente está bien de salud al
menos así lo han dicho las principales
agencias internacionales es una
información que todavía está sujeta a
alguna confirmación por parte de las
mismas autoridades aunque en este
momento pues no se sabe quién es la
autoridad concreta allí en este país en
este momento de transición pues éste
también empezó a reinar entre la
ciudadanía que no se hizo esperar y por
supuesto miles de ciudadanos sudaneses
se tomaron las calles de jartúm la
capital y de otras ciudades del país
para mostrar su rechazo a este golpe de
estado y al quiebre de ese proceso de
transición dichas marchas fueron
reprimidas por las fuerzas armadas de
ese país y en ellas murieron alrededor
de 10 personas la inestabilidad política
en sudán también el fantasma de una
guerra civil y el futuro de este país
africano genera una gran incertidumbre
no solamente en la región el golpe de
estado de sudán y también las
consecuencias que esto puede traer para
el continente africano es nuestro tema
de debate aquí en france24 y para
realizar este tema hemos invitado a
ricardo benítez él es coordinador de
investigación del centro de estudios de
política internacional de la universidad
de buenos aires y también del área de
explorando áfrica también está con
nosotros beatriz escobar christian y
ella es doctora en asuntos africanos
está enfocada en temas específicos de
sudán y de etiopía es docente de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
el estudio de france 24 está con
nosotros alfonso soria ex embajador de
colombia en la república árabe de egipto
es especialista en temas del magreb y
también es docente de la universidad
externado de la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con sus comentarios y con sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales estamos
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos como france24 guión bajo s
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios para
conocer sus opiniones en torno a este
tema comienzo entonces el debate
preguntándole a ricardo benítez en la
ciudad de buenos aires
y cito esta frase del general
alborán que dijo que haber tomado el
poder allí en sudán era una forma para
evitar una guerra civil en este país
africano como era entonces el panorama
en esta nación para que se haya visto la
amenaza de una guerra civil y que los
militares hayan tenido que tomar el
poder en este golpe de estado
hay una recurrencia en la historia de
sudán y justamente es la debilidad del
poder democrático de los gobiernos
democráticos y la importancia que tiene
la ley militar como garante de la
seguridad del país a lo largo de su
historia han realizado diferentes golpes
de estado justamente con la premisa de
la seguridad nacional
actualmente el contexto de ciudadana ha
cambiado desde el punto de vista
histórico entendiendo desde 2011 sudán
del sur que ha sido nuestros principales
puntos de conflicto es un país
independiente con un conflicto aparte
pero tenemos pendiente a las cuestiones
de sudán kordofán del sur y nilo y nilo
azul la realidad es que ante la
polarización social la crisis esa
política que ha devenido después de la
salida de al bashir ha hecho que grandes
sectores dentro dentro del sector
militar de ciudadanos también podían
encontrar sus posiciones de poder de
alguna manera un poco más amenazadas o
por lo menos dentro del consejo de
transición más debilitada así que en
este sentido se puede entender de que la
toma del poder de alguna manera debe
estar recubierta para proteger e
intereses por unos corporativos sin
embargo una historia con tu cielo lo que
sí se ha podido ver que a medida que se
han generado golpes golpes de estado un
régimen más de tipo militar
generalmente el uso de la violencia o la
búsqueda de un enemigo interno sea los
sudaneses son los darfur y eso quizás
ahora los recordó sanz
de alguna manera ha servido como para
poder consolidar el reglamento
en este sentido
tendríamos 222 ideas o 22 potenciales
escenarios la primera la toma del cielo
para proteger de una guerra civil 11 de
efecto la potencialidad de un nuevo
conflicto en base a la conciliación de
un régimen militar esto sigo esta ronda
con beatriz en la ciudad de mexico para
armar este rompecabezas el punto de
partida para el debate
sigamos armando el panorama de este país
africano que es una realidad muy lejana
américa latina y por eso quiero comenzar
con estos puntos tan básicos beatriz
sobre la realidad que está viviendo este
país que desconocemos acá en américa
latina y que llevó a los militares a
este punto de partida por un medio de un
golpe de estado
si efectivamente como señalaba mi colega
la realidad de sudán ha sido la realidad
de un país marcado continuamente por el
conflicto
desafortunadamente sudán hacia la
independencia prácticamente como un país
en conflicto y a partir de los años 50
cuando esto sucede ha sido muy difícil
resolver las múltiples situaciones que
han entrado en juego en este país
algunos pensaban que en el 2005 con la
independencia de sudán del sur se
resolverían los asuntos pero la práctica
mostró que en realidad esto no sucedió
la práctica mostró que sudán tiene
todavía muchos frentes muy problemáticos
como ya lo señalaba mi colega y es por
esta razón que ha habido una serie de
protestas a lo largo de la historia en
la más reciente fue la que llevó
justamente a la destitución de al bashir
pero esto no significó una solución al
final de los problemas sino que los
problemas han continuado
el nuevo gobierno heredó del gobierno de
al bashir una economía en crisis
y toda esta situación con el commit pues
no he hecho sino
complicar aún más la situación
ya lo largo de este año hubo varios
intentos de golpe de estado este fue ya
la consagración digámoslo así de muchos
intentos a lo largo de este año alfonso
aquí en el estudio de france 24 estamos
viendo el panorama al interior del país
lo que sucedía allí pero vamos un poco
más arriba de las fronteras de sudán a
la región que significa sudam para la
región de esa parte de áfrica
inestabilidad yo pensaría que el tema de
sudán pone de relieve la falta de
liderazgo regional creo que yo pensaría
cuando el tema de los no alineados
cuando había una figura como él como
buteflika que podría llevar los temas de
los no alineados hacer un liderazgo
después de la partida de omar al bashir
en sudán se ha generado una cierta
inestabilidad
hay todos los líderes regionales están
ocupados con sus temas locales uno no
podría decir y tampoco son líderes que
tengan valores democráticos entonces uno
podría ver hoy en día que el que en
cierta manera el hecho de esas crisis
que hay donde hay una participación del
de los militares es como la normal en la
región y llama también la atención es
decir que la mayoría de la situación de
libia genera una incertidumbre la región
porque eso hace que la falta de
liderazgo y el tema de libia hace que se
genere otro factor de inestabilidad en
la región y creo que también hay que hay
que ver si hay que hacernos una pregunta
interna si realmente cuando nosotros
hablamos de los valores democráticos si
son importantes para está en la región
entonces yo creo que ese es el gran
interrogante que hay que hacerse si la
comunidad internacional vamos a seguir
hablando democracia cuando el hecho de
tener militares y los y favorecer a los
militares en otros momentos determinados
de la historia ha sido importante para
el resto del mundo y avalando unos
gobiernos dictatoriales que te llevan
muchísimas décadas allí en el poder como
el de el mismo albañil que terminó en en
2019 pero no es solamente sudán el único
país que tiene conflictos en este
momento en la región etiopía está
teniendo conflictos en el norte de su
región también somalia que no está muy
lejos de allí pasó a preguntarle a
beatriz si se puede considerar éste como
un golpe de estado consumado porque
hemos visto a las personas saliendo a
las calles para rechazar este golpe de
estado para reclamar ese proceso de
transición que debía durar supuestamente
dos años y llevar a unas elecciones
democráticas tal y como las conocemos en
exide en occidente se puede hablar ya de
un golpe consolidado y además tomando en
cuenta lo que dije al inicio del
programa que el primer ministro ya fue
liberal que está en su casa tranquilo
con su esposa
si efectivamente ya fue liberado y
algunos analistas consideran que no se
puede hablar de un golpe consolidado
justamente por esta posición tan activa
de la sociedad civil por el interés que
ha tomado en tratar de combatir este
nuevo golpe de estado sin embargo
también hay otros que consideran que el
intento de golpe que hubo en septiembre
fue una especie de prueba piloto para
para ver cómo
reaccionaría la comunidad internacional
y cómo podría reaccionar la comunidad
sudanesa y en ese sentido bueno pues
creo que fue una postura digamos
inteligente por parte de los golpistas
entonces desde mi punto de vista todavía
no está bien consolidado pero
desafortunadamente podría estar
apuntando el escenario que ya que si no
se toman acciones rápidas es si se va a
generar ya un una nueva situación de
pues de ataque a la democracia
riccardo en la ciudad de buenos aires
vía 3 menciona este intento de golpe de
estado en septiembre eso no fue
suficiente también para que los
organismos internacionales prendieron
todas sus alarmas sobre lo que podría
suceder en este país y también al
interior de sudán no no fue suficiente
para alertar al gobierno interino de un
posible golpe de estado como lo ve usted
yo creo que el gobierno interino si tomo
toma en consideración es esa posibilidad
incluso sin la necesidad de casos un
intento de golpe de estado combinamos
que desde el inicio de la transición
hubo una buena fuerte puja entre los
sectores civiles que fueron los que
iniciaron las protestas contra el bayern
que eventualmente activaron al sector
militar para y lo presionaron como para
que tomara cartas en el asunto a partir
de ahí es que cuando los militares se
adhiere a la revolución al bashir saleh
del poder sin embargo algo que
entendieron entendió la sociedad civil
de sudán a diferencia de la de egipto
que se salas a la comparación es que
debían seguir presionando y
movilizándose para garantizar la
transición democrática a partir de ahí
el consejo de transición entra en una
puja importante donde saben que los
militares tratan en un principio de
tener todo el control dentro del consejo
de transición y los civiles pujan por
tener una presencia comenzamos con el
debate de civil y militar si es militar
o civil si es paritario y demás en este
sentido creo que la fragilidad del
sector si bien en la historia de
sudaneses reconocidas bocas de la janda
lugar y a desarrollar por lo menos de
considerar es una opinión personal aún
así ha habido varios movimientos estuvo
el bloqueo de puerto ciudadano es un
tiempo estuvo un intento por prestado
hace poco y de alguna manera el sector
militar era la principal amenaza a el
sector civil dentro del consejo de
transición
creo que este movimiento de alguna
manera es una transformación dentro de
la lid política que quede llegaba la
transición los militares se entienden de
que ellos son los que deben garantizar
esa transición y eventualmente llevar a
una constitución que queda una manera
garantice su forma de dar sudan mientras
que los sectores civiles tienen dos
facciones la que entienden de que deben
cooperar con los militares para llegar a
una situación de constitución
democrática y eventualmente someter al
poder militar al gobierno civil o
incluso a facciones más radicales que
entienden de que el consejo de
transición debe ser exclusivamente símil
algo que en la práctica inglesa sería
prácticamente inviable riccardo que
había suficientes alarmas para entender
la amenaza del poder y puntualmente la
institucionalidad en qué punto se
encuentra en este gobierno interino que
fue lo que heredaron de el presidente al
bashir y cómo estaba la
institucionalidad hasta el momento del
golpe de estado era muy débil e se
estaba construyendo en proceso de
mejoramiento o cómo estaba
en mi opinión creo que existía una
institucionalidad desde luego los
estándares occidentales no digamos que
democrática omar al bashir como toma de
poder es del 89 tarda unos unos años
donde mantiene un sistema de gobierno
puramente de facto y personalizado y
posteriormente desarrolló una
constitución un sistema de multi
partidos que tratan de alguna manera de
generar un paraguas electoral en el cual
desde luego al bashir de casi el 96
hasta ahora fue hablando con el 90 por
ciento de las elecciones es decir
podemos considerarlo desde luego un
sistema electoral que funcionaba a la
líder del poder sin tener mientras tanto
desde el gobierno de bashir por los
conflictos de arthur y como hay también
un sol ante el suelo y poder militar
adquiere una gran capacidad no solamente
política sino también económica y en
este sentido entendemos que quizás en la
puja quisieran las puestas que sean los
militares para oponerse a bashir si rita
que así como como elemento central del
régimen ya había perdido la suficiente
legitimidad entonces directv opinión que
el cálculo político es saquemos al
bashir vemos una transición
volvamos a la rueda desde cero cambiar
todo para que no cambie nada entendido
ricardo le pido por favor que sea más
puntual para poderle dar paso también a
los otros invitados y analizar más más
aristas de este tema alfonso a nivel
internacional
la unión africana tiene que jugar aquí
un papel importante destacado que puede
hacer la unión africana en este caso y
algunas de las potencias regionales no
sé a egipto o sudáfrica que tal vez está
muy lejos quien puede jugar allí y lo
más importante es que en estas crisis en
los países africanos siempre ha
funcionado la filosofía que los
problemas hay que resolverlos de manera
interna al interior no hay nosotros
vemos la transición por ejemplo que
están túnez es muy lenta es tranquila
pero las decisiones han sido tomadas de
manera democrática al interior de ellos
sin ninguna después con una relativa
ausencia de la presión extranjera aquí
me parece que podrían el presidente al
si si podría en cierta manera hay una
hay un cierto interés de mantener la
región y ejercer un liderazgo pero
consideró que el tema aquí aquí la
incapacidad es de legitimar el poder
militar
y esa legitimación no la va no va por
ahí y el tema también es cierto que hay
que ver cuáles son las fuerzas y las
fuerzas externas que no que no las
exigencias democráticas no es la primera
condicionalidad en el relacionamiento
internacional pensemos en toda esa esa
presión que hay de rusia en la región
pensemos en la presión de chinas del
punto de vista económico en el punto de
vista militar la presencia de rusia en
la región y que igualmente se ve también
en el conflicto libio el tema también de
todos los mercenarios que están por la
región entonces todo esto y el hecho de
que los eeuu piense que como ver los
sacado la lista de los terroristas y
haber suspendido hoy la ayuda eso es
queda como la carne de que directo y
listo para para que otros tipos externos
podrían aprovechar la situación el tema
hoy en día creo que en la unión africana
y no solamente está la unión africana
podría también los los países de la liga
árabe podría de pronto el protagonismo
de los no alineados podría entrar un
momento jugar un papel pero aquí el tema
es si el hecho de legitimar un tema o un
una iniciativa popular que fue como
legitimar a unos militares que se van a
quedar a ir porque la región toda misma
pertenece y hay una una necesidad de los
temas de los temas de protección de la
población y todo de los temas de propio
de proteger las fronteras sería es lo
más importante por eso está el tema
militar
beatriz su opinión al respecto sobre el
apoyo de la comunidad internacional
claramente lo que uno puede entender es
que para este proceso de transición tal
vez la comunidad internacional sí lo
estaba acompañando
suficientemente cerca porque si llegamos
a este golpe de estado es porque tal vez
la comunidad internacional no estaba
guiando mucho pero ya alfonso nos indica
que áfrica se resuelven las cosas al
interior de sus fronteras sin tener
tanto apoyo de de organismos
internacionales y tampoco pidiendo mucha
ayuda de las potencias regionales
sí bueno de hecho incluso en educación
es rechazando la posible ayuda o
intervención depende del punto de vista
con que se le vea no debemos olvidar por
ejemplo la posición férrea que tuvo la
unión africana respecto de
la no captura de al bachir para llevarlo
a la corte penal internacional esto es
un ejemplo justamente de muchos temas
que han sido una especie de tabú en el
continente africano
y el tema de la posible intervención
extranjera es uno de ellos en cuanto a
otros países efectivamente yo creo que
la el acompañamiento en general ha sido
lento y la reacción bueno es la típica
reacción en frente a los golpes
militares y anunciar el retiro de la
ayuda por ejemplo por parte de eeuu o
por parte de la unión europea en
posibles medidas de sanción pero en
realidad hemos visto que hablando de la
historia estas medidas no han tenido
mucho éxito
incluso un bloqueo importante y el
gobierno de al bashir pues en los hechos
se puede mantener durante muchísimo
tiempo a pesar de este bloqueo claro
hugo y toda una labor para tratar de
conciliar intereses pero en realidad
creo que la respuesta de la comunidad de
la comunidad internacional generalmente
no es la más adecuada o la que pueda
llevar de una mejor manera a combatir
este tipo de golpes o de situaciones ya
tris y un efecto bola de nieve la región
ya mencionaba que varios países cercanos
a sudan que tienen frontera con sudán
también están experimentando problemas
al interior de sus fronteras etiopía
somalia que viven pues en una guerra
civil es un estado prácticamente fallido
hay mercenarios en la república
centroafricana mercenarios
rusos esto podría generar de pronto un
efecto bola de nieve allí en la región y
también lo pregunto viéndolo lo que
hemos visto en los últimos meses en el
sahel y en áfrica occidental
si efectivamente es una cuestión que se
retroalimenta
la situación en sudán puede llevar a un
efecto bola de nieve pero a la vez la
situación en los países vecinos
contribuye a la inestabilidad en sudán
en toda la región en todo el cuerno de
áfrica y esta parte de áfrica del norte
hemos visto desafortunadamente una un
debilitamiento o una poca presencia en
los hechos de la sociedad civil
como se desarrollaron los
cimientos después de la primavera árabe
en egipto es un ejemplo y también hemos
visto un escenario de continuo conflicto
de ciudad con otros países limitado pero
es algo que está siempre ahí y que no
contribuye a la democratización de la
región
paso a preguntarle a ricardo en la
ciudad de buenos aires hablábamos de la
transición hablamos de las exigencias
que han tenido los ciudadanos en las
últimas horas a raíz de este golpe y
ellos piden un gobierno completamente es
civil voy un poco en línea lo que usted
estaba mencionando de los militares y el
historial que ha tenido allí en sudán
quien podría ser una figura civil que
pueda llevar al país a una transición
puede volver el primer ministro que
estaba en el poder hasta hace unas
cuantas horas y el país definitivamente
va a quedar en manos de los militares
como lo ve usted porque ha claramente
una desconexión entre lo que quieren los
ciudadanos y lo que quieren los
militares y lo que se estaba tratando de
organizar digamos como un gobierno
democrático
se trata de una característica
particular de la de la política de
ciudad que es la racionalización y en
este sentido en vez de sentarse a
debatir o a consensuarse generalmente se
toman posiciones de situaciones
controversiales generalmente de
enfrentamiento conflictivas
algunos justamente análisis marcan el
tema de que la extracción sigilosa tiene
estar estas dos estas dos disidencias
que sinceramente no tendría una
respuesta adecuada quien podría ser por
dos motivos una porque no ha habido
muchas figuras civiles a lo largo de la
historia de la ciudad que podamos decir
estas están por de por debajo de la red
y que eventualmente puedan surgir 'no
dejando que el estado es crítico
historial en la comunidad nacional ha
trabajado por varios organismos y
eventualmente cuando fue la revolución
el vuelve a ciudad y creo que tanto
también puede ser una figura que es
importante para la comunidad
internacional pero quizás a nivel
interno también la falta de legitimidad
creo que el actor principal a nivel
interno han sido los militares y
eventualmente no tienen una comunicación
importante con la sociedad civil así que
en este sentido sí algún líder de la
sociedad civil eventualmente tendrá que
salir de las fuerzas que están en esta
inmovilización en este momento
viatri su opinión al respecto sobre
quién podría surgir como un líder civil
o definitivamente le quedó el camino
libre a los militares allí pues
esperemos que no definitivamente pero si
se ve como algo complicado justamente
como se ha explicado ahorita el
historial de sudán ha sido marcadamente
militar y esto mismo ha hecho que no
haya figuras demasiado destacadas por
parte de la sociedad civil y la otra
cuestión es que es una realidad que
pensamos a veces en la sociedad civil
como en un bloque pero en realidad es
una serie de intereses que a veces
pueden coincidir pero a veces son
encontrados entonces yo también veo
difícil no necesariamente imposible
porque en su momento apareció la figura
dejando y pudo gobernar durante este
tiempo pero si veo como una cuestión
complicada el ascenso de líderes civiles
en un panorama tan fuertemente
militarizado
alfonso aquí en el estudio de france 24
le preguntó precisamente por el papel de
los militares a lo largo de la historia
de áfrica el papel que han tenido en los
gobiernos y dictaduras muy largas
apoyados y afianzados precisamente por
los militares es una constante en este
continente es una constante y solamente
ojos por la participación de la sociedad
sí pero los valores democráticos a veces
que nosotros tenemos en américa latina
son distintos en los de áfrica
y desafortunadamente
hay hay una desde desde los procesos de
independencia alguna asociación del
tema de seguridad de la seguridad de
fronteras la seguridad para mantener con
en la parte del gobierno yo creo muy
difícil hay un camino muy largo para una
sociedad civil para un gobierno civil en
sudán de acuerdo a la experiencia dicen
solamente es constatar que cuando uno se
escogemos democráticamente y cambia la
constitución siendo un militar como lo
que pasó en egipto o sea eso no está hay
una permanencia hay una permanencia
se ha de asociar el tema militar con el
poder y más en los temas de
inestabilidad y hoy en día en esta
región donde están los temas los temas
de seguridad el tema del terrorismo de
todo el aqmi todo el tema del del sahel
todo eso entonces eso encuentra cierto
eco en la población civil de la
necesidad de mantenerlo pienso que es es
importante mover las bases y es
importante generar este tipo de
situaciones donde pueda uno volver pero
la misma comunidad internacional hablan
si se instala dice bueno pues
mantengamos el poder militar lo hacen
como pasa en la región rápidamente
porque ya estamos en el último bloque
del programa como es el concepto de
democracia en áfrica en que difiere con
el concepto que tenemos nosotros que
tampoco es que seamos los grandes
ejemplos de la democracia ni ministra
nacional en américa la noche por ejemplo
en el en el adn de mucho de la de la
mayoría de los pueblos de la américa
latina la democracia es fundamental el
derecho de elegir y ser elegido
de pronto hay una figura que viene de
mensajes épocas densas de las tribus es
decir que hay una persona que da que
provee todo y provee el bienestar
entonces muchas veces no hay una
necesidad de cambiarlo de escogerlo y
nosotros lo vemos por todas las
monarquías del golfo y todo donde uno no
se explica desde un punto de vista
racional desde este lado del hemisferio
como todos los recursos que pertenecen a
todos es administrado por una sola
familia pero le da el bienestar entonces
muchas veces ojo aquí lo importante es
aquí aquí hay que destacar que hay
movimientos civiles en sociedad civil
todo lo que pasa que la realidad el
contrapeso del poder militar y de la
manera como usted tienen tienen el poder
y lo ejercen y el relacionamiento del
exterior es mucho más fácil a partir de
los militares que la sociedad civil
atrás lo vemos lo vemos en ciudad en
donde hay casi 80 partidos políticos
conformados y establecidos allí que
participaban en lo que ellos llamaban un
proceso democrático llegamos entonces a
la recta final del programa riccardo
quiero que lleguemos a las conclusiones
de lo que pueda suceder en este país
africano para los próximos meses días en
se quedan los militares viene un
contragolpe entra a la comunidad
internacional no tenemos la bola de
cristal siempre lo digo no sabemos el
futuro pero cuál es su análisis
creo que el poder militar en este
momento tiene una gran serie de
elementos a favor los muchos se
encuentran vinculados con obtener un
visto bueno por lo menos con otros
líderes regionales que el que se
encuentra el área principalmente asistió
en egipto esto también los vincula con
arabia saudita soy un problema que han
tenido para consolidar los gobiernos en
sudán es el problema económico a lo
largo de la historia
se ha sabido que la con vinculación del
gobierno de sudán guardias saudita es
fuerte y aparentemente el intercambio de
mercenarios para pelear el semen también
devino en un mayor ingreso para para los
militares y creo que algunos sectores de
la región pueden entender que un poder
militar fuerte de alguna manera es un
actor viable y como decían previamente
la cláusula democrática que esa no es la
más prioritaria por lo menos en los
factores que realmente juegan a nivel
internacional va a haber una presión
probablemente por volver al ciclo
probablemente sudáfrica quizás sea
cartas en el asunto porque presionó para
que haya un consejo de transición entre
militares y civiles eventualmente tuvo
éxito pero desde el otro lado hacia el
oriente de sudán no tenemos actores ya
va a tener un golpe de estado libia está
en guerra centro de áfrica no tienen
casi gobierno
y si vamos un poco más allá llegamos a
marruecos o túnez también estamos en
otro proceso entonces no creo que haya
muchas ventajas para
consolidar el poder de los élites civil
en sudán por lo menos por por motus
propio a menos que tengan un apoyo
consolidable estar siempre una concilio
desde la presión internacional de jávea
3 para el cierre del programa alfonso su
conclusión
vamos yo creo que el secreto está en los
en lo externo en por ejemplo me llama la
atención la crisis del multilateralismo
imposible sacar una decisión del consejo
de seguridad a la unanimidad está china
que tiene un interés económico y rusia
de volver al port sudán y hacer todo a
volver a ser una base para sus temas
nucleares de sus de sus portaaviones de
sus intereses en la región y creo que
sería después de siria sigue el segundo
lugar donde los rusos están por fuera de
su zona de confort y yo creo que si esos
militares tienen el apoyo del de los
rusos y los chinos en temas económicos y
en temas estrategia va a mantener ese va
manda a verse algún problema y yo creo
que el perú es un tema en la región y es
un tema de también los eeuu el hecho de
traer a un actor como israel el acuerdo
pareciera como vanguardista sudán y
última nos damos cuenta que es un tema
de juego de un momento determinado pero
ni maria sala argumenta región que es
exacto acomodada como antes y beatriz en
la ciudad de mexico la dejó para el
cierre para
y muchas gracias
desde mi punto de vista lo que podría
esperarse es
una presencia continua de los militares
pero creo que si la sociedad civil sigue
con un papel tan fuerte en contra del
golpe militar como tal
probablemente tenga que limitarse un
poco y maquillarse esta presencia desde
luego todavía falta mucho camino para
que sudán pueda volver aún pueda tener
una normalidad democrática entre
comillas
pero creo que los esfuerzos de la
sociedad civil van a ser fundamentales
en este sentido bueno pues a ricardo
benítez a beatriz escobar y alfonso
osorio aquí en el estudio france24 les
agradezco por haber venido a compartir
con nosotros sus opiniones y puntos de
vista en torno a este tema ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales de france 24 en
nombre del equipo de la producción la
obra garzón y tania herrera les
agradecemos su sintonía y también de los
compañeros de la parte técnica en el
máster sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]